Howard Stern Show here's a song called
the joke you drink of water you want
some you want some alcohol news take a
shot of that nothing like drinking early
in the morning I'm sure you're not used
to drinking this early right I think it
tastes better like that yeah for
breakfast I drink this early on
Christmas no kidding
sure you bet keep that in check I say
though roses you're not up at this time
of the morning no no definitely not in
fact I didn't you really go to bed ah
all right here we go I'm gonna shut up
during this okay come on as well I won't
jam with you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you feeling nervous aren't you boy with
your quiet voice and impeccable
[Music]
don't ever let them steal your joy and
your gentle ways to keep them from
running
they can kick dirt in your face
dress you down and tell you that your
place is in the middle when they hate
the way you shine I see you talking on
your shirt trying to hide inside of the
and hide how much it hurts
[Music]
yeah
little spinner
ha
Oh
which
the Howard Stern Show